[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video were going to be discussing
Harry Potter the Weasleys the Dursleys
and why on earth harry didn't just live
with the Weasley family
why did Harry year-after-year return to
a place where he wasn't wanted the
Dursleys home now I know they're related
Tim but they are awful people and they
really abused Harry
how could Harry Potter the boy who
famously survived an attack from Dark
Lord I've nowhere to stay but with them
instead of being celebrated for being
magical the Dursleys hated Harry for it
they hated any and all things that
weren't normal this hatred stemmed from
his aunt petunias belief that her
parents prefer to a magical sister to
her which forever made her despised the
entire Wizarding World
when Vernon and petunia met the tuna
confessed to Vernon that her sister was
a witch this led to them bonding over
despising all things magical each year
at the end of the school term students
are sent back to home to spend time with
their families and each year
Harry visits the Weasleys on his way
back home so why doesn't he just stay
there why bother going back to the
Dursleys
it even seems like the Burrow isn't too
far from the home of the Dursleys
as ron was able to take harry there in
the flying Ford Anglia in what seemed
like a fairly reasonable amount of time
now before we dig further into why Harry
didn't live with the Weasleys the first
thing that should be addressed is the
present state of affairs for love
Weasley family their family is quite
large and consists of Fred George
Charlie
Molly Arthur Ginny bill Percy and of
course Ron obviously there are more
Weasley's but these are the main ones
that were introduced to in the series we
know and love the Weasley family for
both their quirks and the kindness to
Harry throughout the books and films
they really are good people who have
nothing but Harry's best interest in
mind in the time that Harry does spend
with them Molly Weasley takes Harry in
like one of her and no questions asked
come Christmas time is always a plate on
the table for Harry and there's always a
new jumper knitted for him they truly
embrace him as one of their own but one
thing that is hard to ignore is the
financial situation it's suggested quite
a bit in the books and films but the
family don't have a lot of money their
clothes ones home and thrifty attitudes
all sort of suggested this is mainly
because Arthur is the only stream of
income for the entire family
first he worked for the misuse of muggle
artifacts Department and later on he was
promoted and assumed the role of head of
office for the detection and
confiscation of counterfeit defensive
spells
and protective objects department even
if Arthur has quite a healthy salary
it's hard to imagine that it would be
easy to support a family of his size so
one thought that I had was that Harry
doesn't live with the Weasleys because
they can't afford the additional expense
the issue with this is at the Weasleys
love Harry and I'm sure that they would
do anything to accommodate him at living
with them so money simply can't be the
reason that he didn't live with them
there's got to be something else the
real reason that Harry lived with the
disease and it seems like it always
comes down to this was Harry's bloodline
Harry's Aunt Petunia was of course the
sister of Harry's mother Lily Potter
because Bettina was harried but relative
people held the belief that Lily's act
of sacrificial protection would continue
on and be transmitted through petunia
when I say Lily's sacrificial protection
I am of course referring to the powerful
counter charm that Lily put a cast on
Harry when she was being attacked by
Lord Voldemort a sacrificial protection
charm that can performed when someone
sacrifices their own life willingly and
out of deep pure love to save the life
of someone else
Dumbledore explains this himself while
you can still call home the place where
your mother's blood dwells there you
cannot be touched or harmed by Voldemort
He shed her blood but it lives on in you
and her sister her blood became your
refuge
you need returned there only once a year
but as long as you can still call it
home there he cannot hurt you your aunt
knows this I explained what I had done
in the letter I left with you on her
doorstep
she knows that allowing Neuhaus room may
well have kept you alive for the past 15
years so even though the Dursleys
treated Harry like trash in a tragic
turn of events he was actually still
safer with the Dursleys than with anyone
else as sure he could have lived with
the Weasleys and soaked up the love but
he
have been as safe there ultimately
keeping Harry Potter alive was the top
of priority and that's all for this
video if you enjoy the content please be
sure to like the video and subscribe to
the channel until next time you're a
wizard Harry
[Music]
you